Speaker 1: One of the things I think is really
important for all of us to be able to do is to
figure out when we see a headline, when we
start seeing something, enter the discussion
and get repeated over and over again. And it's a
major claim. We need to be able to figure out for
ourselves, is it backed by evidence or is this
disinformation or misinformation? And we have
the perfect example today. There is a new I'm
going to use some of the words they're using,
even though they're B.S., quite frankly. There
is a new, quote, study about COVID vaccines from,
quote, Florida floating around, which I started
seeing over the weekend during my live streams. I
saw some of the people in the chat saying, David.
New study from Florida says that COVID vaccines
increase heart attacks by 84% in the month
after one is vaccinated. When you get a vaccine,
your odds of a heart attack go up 84% for
the month after you've received that vaccine.
So the first question with all of these things
is, does it pass the sniff test? So with some
of these things, you know, it turns out we
don't breathe oxygen. We actually breathe
really light water, you know, so I don't know. We
would say this doesn't even pass the sniff test.
It's not really even worth looking into. Now,
let's imagine it were true that getting a COVID
vaccine increases your chances of a heart attack
by 84%. We would be talking about so many heart
attacks, heart attacks and deaths that we would
have heard about this more so more quickly than
two years into vaccination. But let's imagine
that we want to take this seriously and explore
it. The source of this is Florida's surgeon
general, Joseph Ladapo, a known anti-vaccine
voice. And Ars Technica has a really good write
up about this so-called analysis. And he put
out a statement on Friday that men age 18 to 39
should not get the COVID vaccine. Why not? Well,
he claims to have an analysis called exploring the
relationship between all cause and cardiac related
mortality following COVID 19 vaccination or
infection in Florida Residents A Self-controlled
Case Series Study. There is then a press release
about the analysis, so now we're like a layer
removed. Now it's a press release about an
analysis. The press release says COVID vaccines
cause an 84% increase in the relative incidence
of cardiac related death among males 18 to 39
within 28 days following marina vaccination.
There's a lot of important data in that claim
or important metrics in that claim which we are
going to look at. So let's take a look at the
analysis. One of the things you might notice when
you pull up the analysis is it's supposedly from
the Florida Department of Health, but it's not on
Florida Department of Health letterhead. That's
sort of weird for an analysis supposedly from
the Florida Department of Health. There is no
author is listed on the study. Well, that's really
weird. And of course, it's not peer reviewed,
obviously. I mean, there's not even a claim
that it is or that it's in any journal or
that it's been reviewed in any way. So what is the
analysis that has been done? Well, the first thing
is they did what's called a self-controlled case
series. We're going to talk about what that is.
How should we look at vaccine safety? You would
want to take a group of vaccinated people and
a group of not vaccinated people. Maybe they
get a placebo, the non-vaccinated people. So
no one even knows whether they are or aren't
vaccinated. You match them up demographically
so that in both of these groups you have similar
underlying health statuses, other parameters, age,
etc. and you compare them over a period of
time. Which of the groups over a period of time,
the vaccinated or unvaccinated group has more
infections or more cancer or more car accidents,
whatever? And the idea is you want to make
vaccination. The only variable one group
has the vaccine, the other doesn't. And they are
otherwise identical groups in a self-controlled
case series, which is what was done. There's no
control group. The only people in their study
are the people that are being studied and whose
outcomes are being measured. There's no control
group. It's, you know, got a COVID vaccine died
within 25 weeks. And then they look subsequently
at the group that died within the first four
weeks. And what they wanted to see was, are the
deaths clustered in the first four weeks after
the vaccination, which is considered the risk
period for a vaccine during which a side effect or
a complication could happen. And so they they look
at the first four weeks and then they call weeks,
5 to 25, the control group. That doesn't make
sense. That's not good science. And I'm getting
so wound up that I punched my microphone. Now,
what they also did was they excluded people
from the study who had COVID, died of COVID,
and they excluded people with boosters. Why
would you do that? Wait a second. You want to
study something related to COVID and the vaccine?
You have no control group and you exclude people
from the study who had COVID, died of COVID or
had a booster, meaning they went beyond their
first two dose regimen. Well, that's nonsense.
That doesn't make sense. They also don't actually
have any medical information for cause of death.
They only have death certificates. And as we know,
death certificates through no deliberate attempt
at fraud, don't always represent. The heart of the
matter, for lack of a better term, about how
someone died. Sometimes you die because of a
complication from COVID. That complication goes on
the birth certificate, but not the fact that you
had COVID and the reason you were in the hospital
was COVID. And then a complication came up. Just
as one example. They don't know how many people
died of undocumented COVID cases after one dose
of the vaccine, for example, where one dose of the
vaccine is not considered, that you are protected,
that's not actually a full regimen. Even the
cardiac related causes of death might not be.
The analysis says in it, quote, Cardiac related
deaths were ascertained if a code of i31 52 was on
the death certificate. Thus the underlying cause
of death may not be cardiac related. They're even
saying some of these cardiac related deaths might
not really be cardiac related. They also didn't
separate out people with M RNA vaccines and non-GM
RNA in a clean cut way. They claim to be studying
the effects of RNA vaccines. Remember, the
Johnson and Johnson vaccine is not an RNA vaccine.
They have two classifications. They have
people with an mRNA vaccine and people with
a non Amrani or unknown type of vaccine. You
could have obvious misclassification when those
are your categories. And it also only looked at
men 18 to 39. Now, there's two important things
about that. First of all, they combined 18
to 24 and 25 to 39. Why would they do that
when the underlying data separates those into two
groups 18 to 24, 25 to 39? Why would you combine
them? Well, they don't say. And of course, the
speculation is that by combining those two groups,
you get them the finding that they wanted. This
is a version of what's called the P hacking,
Google P hacking. And you'll very
quickly learn what that is. Last thing,
the number of deaths in the specific group they
studied was 20 during the first four weeks and
then 52 in the so-called control period, 5 to 25
weeks. And the sample sizes are so small and it's
not really a control group that the data are
essentially meaningless. So don't fall for it.
Joseph Ladapo should be more concerned with
the disease outbreak in Florida following the
hurricane and power outages, which is a real issue
after a natural disaster. Then putting together
these bogus so-called analyzes, messing with
the data, no control group, wrong type of study,
on and on and on. So when you see the headline
now, vaccines cause 84% increase in cardiac death.
You now are equipped to understand that
the so-called analysis is completely bogus.